- [Instructor] You or
someone you care about
may have been recently
diagnosed with breast cancer.
This video will help you understand
some available treatment options.
Breast cancer is a disease
where some of the cells in the breast
begin to grow uncontrollably.
Treatments for breast
cancer can include surgery,
radiation therapy,
chemotherapy, hormone therapy,
targeted therapy and immunotherapy.
There are several types of surgery
depending on the size and
location of the tumor.
This video does not cover
all available types of
breast cancer surgery.
During a lumpectomy, the tumor is removed
along with some of the
normal tissue around it.
In a total or simple mastectomy,
the entire breast is removed.
During a modified radical mastectomy,
In addition, some of the lymph nodes
under your arm are removed
and sometimes other tissues in your chest.
Your doctor may also want to
give you radiation therapy.
This therapy uses radiation
to kill the cancer cells
or keep them from growing.
External beam radiation uses a machine
outside the body that aims
radiation at the cancer.
Internal radiation therapy,
also known as brachytherapy,
uses a substance
that gives off radiation
through different types
of delivery devices.
The substance is put inside your breast
where the cancer has been removed.
Chemotherapy uses certain
drugs to kill cancer.
These drugs may treat cancer cells
throughout the whole body
or can be given to treat
cancer cells in one area.
Another treatment option
is hormone therapy.
Hormones are substances
found naturally in your body.
Estrogen is one of these hormones.
Your body uses estrogen
mainly for the growth
and development of your
uterus, breast and ovaries.
However, estrogen can
also promote the growth
of certain hormone receptor
positive cancer cells.
One type of hormone therapy
blocks estrogen from binding
to breast cancer cells,
so it cannot cause cancer
cells to grow and divide.
Targeted therapy is a
treatment option for cancers
that have a specific kind of
marker on the cancer cells.
One therapy targets cells
with markers called HER2.
HER2 is a naturally occurring
protein on your cells
that normally promotes
healthy growth in your cells.
Some cancer cells have
too much of this protein.
This causes the cancer cells
to grow and spread more
aggressively than normal cells.
Targeted therapy drugs are
designed to only attach
to the HER2 proteins on cancer cells.
As a result, the cancer cells
stop growing and may die.
Immuno-oncology also
known as immunotherapy,
helps your immune system fight cancer.
Cancer can sometimes hide
from the immune cells that attack them.
For example, both cancer and immune cells
may have proteins called
checkpoint proteins.
When they attach, attack from
other immune cells is stopped.
Scientists are looking at one
type of immunotherapy drug
that blocks the checkpoint proteins
from attaching to each other.
As a result, the immune cell can attack
and destroy the cancer cell.
Your doctor may prescribe
a combination of the
treatments we've discussed
or different treatment options
than those mentioned here.
If you have questions about breast cancer
or any medications you
have been prescribed,
talk to your doctor.
It is important to take
your medications as directed
and report any side effects you have.